much of my work is that it's even
classical cryptography seems not very
helpful here but in fact most of it is
is its quantum it's pre quantum or
appointed friendly so you can break it
if you had quantum computers but the the
focus of the talk today is going to be
talking about certain classical systems
and perhaps they can give us some
inspiration for some problems that might
be interesting in the quantum world and
so this is sort of just very you know
I'll suggest some open problems but you
know it's the you know there might be
problems with the open problems as well
so a so think of it more as a discussion
and please feel free to interrupt ask
questions and we can sort of deviate in
that direction and I can talk more and
so on okay so starting weights over very
high level I'm going to talk most about
skating quantum program so this is a you
know I'll talk more about the the
classical stuff here this is sort of it
probably a a big challenge problem to
some extent even in the classical world
doing it from from good assumptions so
it might be okay to make strong
computational assumptions but the reason
I'm going to talk about it is that it's
it's really powerful and the fact if we
have it it's possible that any
cryptographic problem that you might
expect in the quantum world if you once
you have the stool you might be able to
solve all those problems so it sort of
really you can in the classical world
itself as a crypto complete primitive so
perhaps in the quantum world it can
serve a similar role but it might itself
be a hard goal here so I'll suggest a
couple of more tangible or problems in
that direction which might involve
solving some specific instances of
obfuscation with special programs and so
and finally I'll talk a little bit about
MPC with with low communication I I
don't know but I have a feeling that
maybe quantum computers could help here
in in solving this problem from
different assumptions multi-party
computation so so please you know if I
use some crypto language it's not clear
please feel free to interrupt ok so here
at pointa might have an advantage things
that we don't expect to see in the
classical world maybe quantum computers
can help ok so let me start by talking
very briefly about office keishon so we
have two parties Alice and Bob and Alice
has some program P in our mind so you
could think about it a circuit the
tuning machine or if in the quantum
world the quantum computer program and
then she wants to somehow office Kate
this program and give it to Bob it says
that Bob can still execute this this
program on his computer just as you
could have executed units no program but
Alice wants this this office gated
version to be unintelligible for Bob so
in particular if the original program
had certain secrets that were hardwired
inside it then Bob should not be able to
dig them out from the office gated
version of this program ok so this is
sort of the informal description of what
authorization is and defining it just
office keishon is is not as maternal to
be rather tricky so the first notion for
office case which was defined by Barak
at all and is this virtual black box
notion and then the notion sort of
fairly natural and the idea is that the
the obfuscated program or C that you
generate with the office keishon the
first condition is it should compute the
same function as the original program ok
so you know it's easy to office K
programs by just outputting a program
you know just always output spot but
that's not very interesting we want the
office gated program to preserve the
functionality of the original program
second we won that office carry program
B at most at most Paulo normally larger
than the original program C or circuit
whatever you have so it should
the cost of office cating should lead to
it most and polynomial slowdown in the
final condition sort of the most
interesting it is that the obfuscated
program should be unintelligible and in
the most natural notion here is the
virtual black box notion which says that
if you have access to the office kated
program it's as good as having oracle
access to that program okay so whatever
an attacker a could do having access to
the office gated version of the the
program you could have done the same
thing if you just had Oracle access to
that program in addition it also knows
that the size or the description length
of the the program because that might be
leaked by the the office catered circuit
itself but it does not leak anything
more than that so in other words the
attacker should not be able to do much
more than having a if you have access to
or C shouldn't be able to do much more
than if you just get access to input
output behavior of the circuit C so this
is sort of a fairly natural notion but
in the same work where a Barak at all
introduced this notion this de pointed
out that this notion is actually
impossible to realize in general so
there are specific circuits though
somewhat esoteric for which this
definition is not realizable question
yes in fact there is a concrete attack
so if you give me an office keishon of a
circuit I can figure out one bit of
information that you couldn't have
figured out if you just had Oracle
access to the program
okay so next I'll define a a an
alternate notion which was also there in
their paper it's called the
indistinguishability obfuscation notion
and the idea here is if you have two
circuits even in situ which compute
exactly the same function so think of
these just being two different
implementations of the same same program
or circuit or underlying function and I
further assume that they are roughly the
same they're exactly the same size but
you know if they're different size you
can pad one of them by just adding a
bunch of no operation gates then I
require that the office the
distributions of efficient on one
circuit is computationally
indistinguishable from the distribution
of the other circuit and this should be
the case even if you know both C 1 and C
2 so this is you know this might seem
like much weaker notion and in
particular this is always it's always
possible to achieve this notion if you
allow the office keishon process to be
inefficient in particular if you have a
circuit you get a circuit C e as input
what you do is you write down all
possible circuits that compute the same
function and pick the lexicographically
first one in that list the smallest one
and output that as the office keishon of
the circuit and then if you're given two
circuits that implement the same
function the output of this inefficient
procedure is going to exactly be the
same so the key challenge here is you
know this is this can always be done and
it's in efficiently but the key
challenges perhaps additionally using
computational assumptions to be able to
office gate efficiently so we want to be
able to outputs or the second in
canonical form which is efficient
this inefficiency then of course it does
not escape at all yes well it office
gates by their achieve the definition
right but it doesn't office gate in some
sense at all this yeah even this obvious
thing is not so obvious if you think
about quantum circuits right because you
cannot write the truth table you need
somehow like compute to operate maybe
compute the unit so you know this might
seem like a weak notion but this oh yes
you see anything about how yes I will
talk about it in an upcoming slide but
yeah it just may be one or two slides
yeah well I mean so the a a in an
inefficient sense you mean right so okay
so but but I'll answer your question in
the next slide after this so just you
know this notion might seem weak and not
answer your question that it does does
hide something on the next slide but
just before I wanted to mention that
there are actually plenty of
applications that you know this sort of
weak notion or seemingly weak notion
already has so in some sense by now if
you can construct something at least in
the classical world if you have an
application where you which you can
achieve using the virtual black box
notion I mean most people will bet their
money on is that you could do some
gymnastics and make it work with with
distinguishability office kitchen as
well and then that's happened for a fair
number of applications yes it seems as
if you know but it is yes exactly
satisfy the definition that's all yes
yes yes so it doesn't achieve what we
really intend it to achieve but but it
does satisfy the definition okay
so to give to answer your question you
know you know why should we care about
you know this this notion it's it feels
pretty weak and the idea is that this
notion sort of achieves the best
possible efficient achieves whatever
best you could hope to achieve why are
any office cater so let's say up to some
size limitations so let's say I have a
circuit see I write the twice and and
then here's my best possible office
keishon of the circuit see I don't know
how to do it you know maybe people will
discover a you know the best possible
office keishon a you know ten years
later 100 years later but what I can do
is I can add my circuit do the same size
well I don't know what the size of the
best office keishon is but let's just
you know let's say somebody tells me
that the best office keishon is going to
be you know of a certain size larger
than the circuit see but I don't know
what how to do that what I could do is
at that time I could office Kate this
best possible office keishon and this
just padded version of the circuit see
and you wouldn't be able to tell whether
I also skated the best possible option
or just this padding right so in other
words even though I don't know what the
best possible office keishon is this
sort of a cheese security close to what
the best possible office kitchen could
have achieved so this is
I mean in order for this to really be
meaningful this is relying on efficient
yes yes yes you could be like undoing
that for yes yes yes yes yes first
Thurgood this whole argument would break
down yes well I mean the office came the
obfuscated circuit itself is not big
only the running type of the office
cater is big here you only care about
the final like the size of the circulars
help with my office cater no no no the
point is the point is that if the
indistinguishably obfuscation procedure
is doing something computationally hard
it could be undoing the first level of
obfuscation yes so you know there's a
tremendous amount of work in trying to
realize office keishon for all circuits
you know even special families of
circuits and in some cases a you know
from from from from some from standard
assumption which are you know even in
the classical world saying you know just
the picture off you know this is already
too outdated by two years and so there
are a lot of different works here and
it's still a in active area and we still
don't have a construction based on - you
know established assumptions but you
know with that leaving that aside I want
to ask a more challenging questions is a
one of them the the the simpler one
perhaps among them is skin quantum you
know the power of quantum help office
gate classical problems perhaps better
than then we can even just do
classically I don't know the answer but
you know if you have thoughts on item
madoka m-- even for simpler tasks this
would be interesting I'll talk about one
specific task where something like this
would be meaningful and give us an
application which is post quantum and
and for which those constructions are
known currently even heuristic Li and
second you know even more challenging
question would be can we office gate
quantum
itself so instead of just classical
programs can we you can are off the
skater take a quantum program as input
and office get that yes that's you know
it's possible in fact for large class or
large families of programs classically
indistinct ability office keishon is as
good as VBB office kitchen you can
actually prove that so if you're looking
at special classes of programs then you
could get the stronger notions yeah that
holds for special classes of programs
yes so how the impossibility roughly
works is let's say you have a tuning
machine and you are for skated it what
you could do is you could take the
office cater to any machine and feed it
to itself those are the kinds of
programs that are ruled out so I'm not
sure if that creates a problem in the
quantum world so - okay yes thanks for
pointing it out yes so here I'm just
trying to office get classical programs
but you now the office cater program and
the office keishon process could run a
quantum computer so right now the
classical task you know I'm trying to
office Kate a classical program I'm
restricted to only using a classical
computer
maybe it doesn't offer any more power
but perhaps you know that's I don't know
the answer to that question and I'm not
an expert to to be able to answer that
question but you know if someone has an
opinion them yeah okay
so you know this is this might seem like
already you know these are sort of big
problems I wanted to to do the
impossibility result they are there any
poll yes yeah or even VBB for all the
families I'm not aware so you know yeah
they were okay you risk like some
suggestions
okay so you know these are Mazar tall or
difficult questions but you know I do
want to talk about some you know special
cases which might be more tangible here
and and and through this I'll start with
this concept of randomized encoding sort
of this very simple in an elegant
concept and has had tremendous
applications in in cryptography and the
idea is we have Alice and she holds the
program P and an input X okay so unlike
office Kesha now she also knows the
input X which is off of interest and she
wants to encode both the program and the
input not just the program but they
input along with and send this encoding
to to Bob so that he can use this
encoding to compute P of X well you
should be asking well you know if I'm
just sending a min encoding of P of X
and the ball is for Bob to only learn P
of X then I could have just computed the
effects and sent it to Bob and and the
the the the the non-trivial ax T comes
from the fact is that we want this
encoding function to be simpler than
actually computing the function P of X
yes yes yes so Bob would do all the hard
work
Alice would do something you know
encoding process which is much simpler
and and that's it so the other question
could be well why doesn't Alice just
send P and X and the clear to Bob and
that's where the security requirement
comes in which says that the encoding of
P of X a P comma X does not reveal
anything more than the output P X so Bob
does not given this encoding does not
learn anything more than P X so it
doesn't learn what P is or what X is
besides the the size of the program and
the input X if it was a tuning machine
or something like that but but Bob
doesn't learn anything more than that
okay
you have access to be obtained in the
clear and so in the classical world sort
of the or classical crypto world yeah so
this that's why it's sort of a
non-trivial for example and when you
compare it with the Deaf edgy and Union
fhe you typically require the size of
the communication to remain small here
I'm not even requiring that so
communication could be large and and in
the the typical notion of simplicity
that classical cryptographers considered
is where encoding function has low depth
it could have large parallel complexity
but it's it's a low depth circuit so
that's typically consider here I want to
mention that this is a it might seem
like a much weaker notion than
obfuscation but note that if in cases
where you know P was something like a
tuning machine and the the the size of
the encoding of P comma X is smaller
than the size of P of X so if you can
generate such an encoding scheme where
the amount of work Alice does is really
small independent of the time it takes
to compute P and in fact the size of
this thing is also small then you can
use this kind of an encoding to get
full-blown indistinguishable so by
efficient it's not just running time it
could be more work in one sense but less
work in another so for example if you're
computing a little or DEP circuit it's
okay to do it you know polynomially more
work but by parallel computation but you
know the depth of the computation should
be small the encoding process so for
example classically we know methods
where you can do this in cording with
depth just three so the depth of the
circuit will just be to you'll be really
wide circuit but the depth of the
circuit will just be three it's a
non-trivial result from from eik
or foreign it's it's it's a really
beautiful result but you know I won't go
into the technicality but
yes so yeah so you know this is sort of
a non-trivial statement here and think
of let's say this P was a tuning machine
and the encoding when I generate the
encoding for it
the size of the encoding is let's say
really small so Bob can somehow unpack
that material it's sort of like a zip to
version of the output and you can unpack
that material so if you can do something
like this then it's a I can give you the
high level idea of how you could use it
to get full-blown office kitchen is that
I'll give you an a packing which outputs
to backings so think of a program P the
first packing outputs to packing switch
output on input more packing on inputs
that start with 0 and in package with
that start with 1 and now these two
packing can output more packings
so obviously there's an exponential
number of packings but you only need to
pursue down one part the specific
packing that you want to compute and
once you get there you can use that tool
under I mean it's a very high level
ideas but but you can sort of amplify it
and it's sort of a non-trivial result
there and certainly to have security go
through you it involves more non to
reality but no no it's just you know the
perfect technique sir yeah yeah so
that's non-trivial but you know the high
level idea is sort of fairly simple
right so think of let's say this P of X
is think of encoding as a zip to version
of P of X right so the zipped version is
capable of generating P of X and now you
can think of exponential compressing
just using a merkel 3 or something like
that something very high level okay
most of them hardness of getting an
application isn't getting this random
and cool yeah so but you know this is it
might seem like a much simpler task but
this is only in the case when you have
you know in the sizes are smaller it's
it's very interesting to realize this
primitive without that constraint as
well right so that that's yes yes yes so
for example a you know if you were just
to think about computing a program P
right let's say I have a quantum
computer which is just incapable of
computing large depth circuit
applications as well yeah but this is
just one of the you know perhaps even
non cryptographic applications okay so I
think that you know one natural question
perhaps taking inspiration even from the
previous talk is can Alice encode a
quantum program classically right that
would be sort of amazing where Alice
could and there I don't really even care
about the sizes of these things it's
just that other somehow it takes a
program and an input and massages have
to come within according all classically
and and then sends it to Bob who can
just do all the the quantum computation
and get the effects from it so Bob is
quantum so this is like the the
strongest thing I can imagine I don't
know if it's possible
Bob is quantum alice is completely
classical I just Alice is completely
trusted and and and she doesn't get
anything from Bob so Bob you know if
there's no real trust in placed in Bob
as well it's just that Bob needs to
learn the effects him you want to say
that he doesn't learn anything more than
that
yeah okay so this is a but you know this
is this would be sort of the the perhaps
an ultimate goal there could be weaker
questions that you could consider where
you know alice's also quantum perhaps
you know can compute quantum circuits of
low depth for example where you could
place requirements on you know the size
of p of x or or what have you so you
could have multiple such simplicity
requirements on on the encoding of P
comma X and expect Bob to learn just B
of X and nothing more from from that yes
so in this said no in this case no
question so the point is when I give him
a packing he unpacks it the the thick of
the packing is yielding exponentially
many packing small and you eventually
getting the the choice you feed your
input from the fact which packings you
unpack yeah yeah so it sort of like the
ggm construction for okay a more
questions okay so this was the the first
question I want to ask and I think it's
a by the way one point I'm gonna mention
it is that it might be possible to do
things like this at least in the
classical world it's very much possible
to do it from just one-way functions so
you may not even need to assume public
key assumptions lwe for for doing this
in the quantum world in in several cases
so a second application and I think it
sort of comes more naturally now that we
have fhe perhaps the next step in the
classical world this was sort of the
next step from from standard assumptions
perhaps we can do attribute based
encryption that supports quantum
policies and so let me just describe
what this primitive is the idea is we
have a key authority and the SPEA
thority generates a public key and a
master secret key so the public keys for
is distributed to all the world and
master secret keys kept private so
here's the public key distributed to
everybody
now let's say the key authority issues
the secret key to a user and and this
user is in the PC for for the conference
crypto and and the secret key is
supposed to be for those attributes so
he has the attribute that he's a PC
member and for the crypto conference and
then another the key Authority uses the
master key master secret key msk to
generate another key for another user SK
Prime with attributes that he again is
also a PC member but from let's say
discount for this dis conference here oh
crap at this point the key the key
Authority has no role to play it leaves
the system the master secret key is
destroyed and an encrypted comes along
and he encrypts a a message with this
policy so what this policy says is that
anybody can decrypt with their secret
key as long as it satisfies the
following policy either they're a board
member so they're perhaps trying to
figure out whether there was a initial
plagiarism and they're trying to figure
out whether you know board member can
decrypt it or if you're a Memphis a
member bar only of crypto not-not-not
Europe and indeed generates the
ciphertext and the idea is you know of
course he publishes the ciphertext and
leaves and the idea is that this PC
member should be able to decrypt because
he satisfies the policy while this PC
member should not be because he does not
satisfy the policy and the security
should hold even if the attacker
you know colludes with other people who
individually do not satisfy the policy
so this is a primitive that we do know
from standard assumptions the GVW gave
this beautiful construction in 2013 from
from lwe it's post quantum but it sort
of a very natural question that now that
we have fhe to ask that can we do
attribute based encryption with quantum
policy so so gorbunov a quentin ottenby
so a stock 13 so this a you know paper
considers policies where you can have
the policy can be in this it could be an
arbitrary circuit by the classical
circuits and you know it's off the the
very next thing after fhe that one can
imagine and so sort of a very natural
shouldn't you consider here yes
individually if you have each of whom
would not satisfy them yes yes so I
think that that's something I mean I'll
have to think more about it but that's I
would guess that that's that should be
doable as well
there should be variants of it in the
literature I don't know exactly what -
yeah secret sharing so that's a that
could be but for general access
structure you need the strong
assumptions there right so so monotone
circuits then yes otherwise you need
stronger assumptions but here the
question is just for so maybe the
question is also interesting in in those
contexts where you want to construct
where the policy could be quantum there
so yeah
no questions
okay so yeah so they can encrypt or
specify your quantum policy so that that
that would be interesting here and
perhaps it would be the next step after
you know that now that we have fhe
constructions okay the the last problem
I want to talk about may not seem
immediately related but I think it's
it's it's it's very interesting in and I
don't know if quantum computers will be
helpful in solving this but right now we
don't have any post quantum schemes for
realizing that so even here is strictly
speaking we have no candidates which can
achieve this task oh let me start with
something very basic so for what we call
non interactive key exchange there's
something that Diffie and Hellman put
forth and the idea is that we have Alice
and Bob they have public keys PK a and P
KB and they want to come up with a
shared key kab with zero interaction so
what I mean by that is that Alice should
be able to use her secret key ska and
Bob's public key PK be to compute kab
and analogously Bob should be able to
use Alice's public key and and her own
and his own secret key SK be to compute
the same shared key kab and the security
is an attacker who has access to just
the two public he should not be able to
to get anything so that when we're
looking at two parties we know how to do
it from from lwe but the moment we turn
to a more than two parties the question
in the quantum world is completely open
so we know no post quantum schemes even
heuristically speaking and then so the
three party construction needs by linear
map switch which are not resilient to
quantum computers and if you wanted to
do more you need more than three parties
even in the classical world we need
office kitchen to do it so here's a very
I'm going to describe a very very simple
scheme that you know an office kitchen
for a specific program if you could
office Kate it you could realize it and
I think it would be very interesting but
I don't know if porno computers would
help there or not but just putting it
forth so the idea I'll try to do it for
four parties so I have four parties and
they want to establish a shared key such
that any subset of the part so any
individual party can use the public keys
of the rest of the parties and its own
secret key to come up with a shared key
okay and in an attacker who has access
to only the public keys does not learn
anything about the shared key that they
can come up with and the idea is is very
simple and I'm going to use sort of two
cryptography in addition to alpha
station to cryptography a to z1 just a
one-way function and another
pseudo-random function f so what what
each party does is is is that it takes
this function G it's it samples a random
string s so first party s 1 the second s
2 and so on and it computes X 1 X 2 you
know they individually compute X 1 X 2
as sort of their public key and and they
send it out or write it on a bulletin
board this is what's made public these
are their public keys and the secret
keys are the corresponding s values and
their shared key is somehow going to be
magically F the pseudo-random function
with the key K computed on the
concatenation of these four inputs ok so
X 1 X 2 X 3 X 4 so if this is let's say
somehow I haven't described how they're
going to compute this but let's say
somehow these four parties were
magically able to compute this value
then we would be done right because this
is something that they can compute but
let's say somehow other people didn't
have access to this pseudo-random
function then this is just a pseudo
random value in they don't learn
anything so all I need is for these
parties to be able to obtain this and
and this you can do wire just
association of this the following
program and the first party can send an
office Kishin of this program so we have
this program pkware with the key K
hardwired that takes as input x1 to xn
and being for in this case an index I
and s ok well this program checks is you
know if you give it s as input it checks
that G of s if it's not equal
excited outputs bottom that means you
don't have a secret key to one of the
public keys right so if you know sort of
like if you don't have a secret key then
you shouldn't get anything out of it
otherwise if you have one of the secret
keys it just outputs FK on the
concatenation of their public keys so
sort of an office kitchen of a very
simple program here well I guess it's
not very simple but but but somewhat
simple program and if you could do this
we would be able to do realize you know
non-interactive key exchange something
for which we'd have no constructions
even classically for more than three
parties and known constructions in post
quantum for more than two parties but
this would give you constructions for
arbitrary number of parties okay so I'm
skipping over the proof and the proof
has with virtual black box security sort
of perhaps easy to see why this would
work within distinguishability
obfuscation it's not trivial and that's
where you have to use sort of those what
I previously called IO gymnastics to or
what people call gymnastics to sort of
work around those those those caveats
and sort of circumvent them and get a
security proof and this uses puncture
both prfs and so there's some some some
some nice results there which which go
in in building this thing okay so any
questions
okay so this you know this finishes the
the sort of the extensions for the
office kitchen part that I want to talk
about now I want to sort of you know
quickly mention a potential application
for for quantum in the the secure
computation world in there the idea here
is we have a sequence of parties and
they have yes how much time - I'm fine
so okay fine so I think it should be
five minutes okay so I have a bunch of
party the private inputs x1 x2 x3 x4 up
to xn and they want to compute this
function f which is which takes as input
these these private inputs and and
computes this output and gives it to all
the parties ok and we want Sony so F is
classical here a for the simple case and
the security I want is that an attacker
even if it corrupts a subset of these
parties any subset that it that he likes
you should not be able to learn anything
more than what it can learn from the
inputs of the corrupted parties and the
output of the computation and the joint
output of the computation the the sort
of a fundamental notion in cryptography
and in terms of efficiency there are
sort of three parameters one could
consider you know one is what is the
computational cost that party spent what
is the Drowned complexity of this
protocol what's the communication
complexity of the protocol with respect
to the first two questions you know are
understand you've sort of very good
understanding of these two you know we
know how to get almost asymptotically
speaking optimal communicate
computational cost an optimal round
complexity from basically the minimal
assumptions that are necessary for those
tasks but the question of communication
complexity you know there there are
there are some interesting open problems
here that I think deserve work and this
is a if you're talking about
communication cost there so the first
result a which which I want to talk
about is
is for fully homomorphic encryption so
if you have access to fully homomorphic
encryption you can relies multi-party
secure computation with communication
cost independent of the size of the
circuit as being the size of the circuit
that you're trying to compute you can do
that and and and here's a very simple
protocol for doing that so you run a MPC
protocol so I'm trying to realize an MPC
protocol where the communication cost is
independent of the size of the circuit
in computing so the first step I'm just
going to run an MPC protocol that sets
up the public key of a fhe scheme and
secret chairs for of the secret key
among all the party so everybody gets a
share of the secret key and an
individual every individual gets a share
of the secret key and everybody gets
access to the public key PK next party I
just sends an encryption of its input
under pk to everybody else now you know
if you have access to everybody is an
input encrypted form you can just
compute encryption off the output from
there you can just run an MPC to decrypt
C of encryption of C oh thanks and then
everybody gets the output so sort of a
very simple protocol but it relies on
fully homomorphic encryption very
recently there's sort of this celebrated
work by a boil at all where they got a
result from ddh does not post quondam so
this is sort of pre quantum but they
they were the main point being that they
used assumptions with less structure
okay so they got communication costs to
be lets say an improvement of log S and
sort of really cool if you are in the
information theoretic setting with
correlated randomness okay so you know
when you have fully homomorphic ISM in
encryption it's it's a it's a very
powerful tool right if you're looking at
the underlying algebraic structure that
LW gives you has a lot of power so you
can add its additively homomorphic and
there's also multiplication you can do
when you look at things like DDH they
allow you for sort of additive
homomorphism but not that multiplicative
homomorphic properties and
so that kind of if you were to move to
the information theoretic setting in in
in the correlated randomness a model we
know sort of a very recent result where
you can get a log-log s improvement so
he the sort of of course you know if you
have access to fhe break but you know if
you didn't then we were really in bad
shape so the question is well can
quantum computer somehow help and and
could we use the quantum power to reduce
communication cost without use of fhe
note that this question is also
interesting if you just if you do use
fhe but limit the use of fhe right
because fhe is also much slower than
perhaps for example if you just doing
something from one with functions for
example if you could do some fhe but a
bunch of a significant chunk of the work
was done without fhe that could be more
efficient and and you know it's it's
it's worthy seeing if quantum computers
can can help on that so that's all i
wanted to say happy to take questions
[Applause]
questions
more questions
drink okay we all need
[Applause]